Recientemente volé sobre una multitud
de miles de personas en Brasil
tocando música de Georg Friedrich Händel.
También conduje por las calles de Amsterdam,
tocando música del mismo compositor.
Echemos un vistazo.
(Georg Friedrich Händel, "Allegro")
(Video) Daria: Vivo allí en el tercer piso.
(En holandés) Vivo allí en la esquina.
De hecho, vivo a la vuelta de la esquina,
y son bienvenidos.
Hombre: (En holandés) ¿Suena divertido? Niño: (En holandés) ¡Sí!
(En holandés) "Sala de conciertos Händel ".
(Aplausos)
Daria van den Bercken: Todo esto fue en verdad
una experiencia mágica por cientos de razones.
Preguntarán, ¿por qué hice estas cosas?
No son realmente típicas de un músico
en su vida cotidiana.
Bueno, lo hice porque estoy enamorada de la música
y quería compartirlo con tanta gente
como fuera posible.
Todo comenzó hace un par de años.
Tenía gripe, estaba en el sofá de mi casa
y navegando por Internet,
cuando me enteré de que Händel había escrito obras
para teclado.
Bueno, me sorprendió. Yo no sabía esto.
Así que descargué las partituras y empecé a tocar.
Lo que sucedió después fue
que entré en un estado puro
de asombro sin prejuicios.
Fue una experiencia
de estar totalmente maravillada con la música,
como no había sentido en mucho tiempo.
Puede ser más fácil de entender cuando la escuchen.
La primera pieza que toqué
empezaba así.
(Música)
Bueno, esto suena muy melancólico, ¿verdad?
Volví la página y lo que vino después
fue esto.
(Música)
Bueno, esto suena muy vivo, ¿no es así?
Así que en pocos minutos
y, sin haber terminado la pieza,
experimenté dos estados de ánimo bien contradictorios:
hermosa melancolía y pura energía.
Considero estos dos elementos como
expresiones humanas vitales.
La pureza de la música hace que la escuches
de manera muy positiva.
He ofrecido muchos conciertos para niños,
de 7 y 8 años,
y lo que sea que toque, ya sea Bach, Beethoven,
incluso Stockhausen,
o algo de jazz,
están abiertos a oír,
realmente dispuestos a escuchar,
y se sienten cómodos haciéndolo.
Cuando llegan las clases
con niños solo un poco mayores,
de 11 o 12, sentía, a veces, que tenía problemas
en llegarles de igual manera.
La complejidad de la música surge como un problema,
y de hecho, las opiniones de los demás
-los padres, los amigos, los medios de comunicación- empiezan a influir.
Pero los más pequeños no cuestionan
sus propias opiniones.
Se encuentran en este constante estado de asombro.
Creo firmemente que podemos seguir escuchando
como niños de 7 años,
o incluso cuando hayamos crecido.
Es por eso que he tocado,
no solo en salas de conciertos,
sino también en las calles, en Internet, por los aires:
para sentir ese estado de asombro,
al escuchar de verdad,
y para atender sin prejuicios.
Me gustaría invitarlos
a hacerlo ahora.
(Georg Friedrich Händel, "Chacona en sol mayor")
(Aplausos)
Gracias.